et coucou regardez où est ce qu'on est
on est ici on est chez samsung alors on
le voit pas ce cas lorsque le vent
derrière c'est do what turckheim télamon
absence de vue l'accent cadou watch kent
et aujourd'hui on est là pour regarder
les nouveaux smartphones qui viennent
tout juste d'être annoncé en nous les
ont présentées ici en exclusivité on est
chez samsung avant l'annoncé officielle
donc ça c'est vachement bien on a donc
deux modèles intéressants le galaxy à 33
et le galaxy à 53 les deux smartphones
sont 5 j'ai donc là ya plus de questions
de 4 g sand j'ai c'est tout 5 g france
billet comme ça on ne voit rien on sait
alors deux smartphones intéressant on va
c'est décortiqué l'idée aujourd'hui
c'est quoi et bien s'il voulait
présenter de vous expliquer ces deux
nouveaux produits qui viennent compléter
la gamme alors la croupe est tout
doucement parce que la gamme à arrive en
2022 et puis il y aura je pense à
d'autres smartphones qui arriveront
pense effectivement ou à 73 5 g qui
devrait arriver un peu plus tard mais ça
c'est une autre histoire donc venez vous
abonner ce n'est pas déjà fait vous
cliquez sur le petit bouton rouge si les
rouches et que vous n'êtes pas abonné
mais surtout vous actionnez la cloche
pour authentifier qu'une prochaine vidéo
arrivera et ça c'est vachement bien et
puis n'oubliez pas ces smartphones on va
les tester ultérieurement dons pour tout
savoir savoir s'ils sont bien s'il ya au
delà de la découverte eh bien on fait
une chose on s'abonne est inactive la
cloche allez on y va du parti
deux nouveaux smartphones alors
effectivement il ya le à 33,5 jeu qu'on
va regarder on passera un peu plus
rapidement parce que même si c'est un
smartphone qui est intéressant qui est
bien placé qui est très jolie en plus
j'aime bien le design je dirais que la
star aujourd'hui c'est le à 53 5 g parce
que je sais pas si vous le savez mais je
voulais déjà dit avant dans notre vidéo
quand je parlais du a52 a51 du à 52 et
bien dans la gamme à les modèles 50 sur
les modèles qui se vendent le plus et
samsung c'est les modèles de volume
c'est les modèles de masse et c'est
gérer le meilleur rapport qualité prix
parce que ils sont super bien ils ont un
très joli design vous allez retrouver
effectivement un écran infiniti haut
c'est quoi le infiniti haut eh bien
c'est le petit trou euros la petite
encoche la petite bulle comme vous
voulez qu'ils se trouvent au centre qui
est sympa avec un petit menton à dire
une partie noire qui est quand même
assez discrète sur le bas des contours
créée fin et un design qui est super
sympa a contrario lui à 33 pas forcément
va être un peu plus bas au niveau des
tarifs et le design va être un peu moins
sexy qu'on peut pas tout avoir à faire
des compromis ça on s'en doutera on a un
écran infiniti eu eu c'est quoi et bien
fait de voiliers c'est la partie du haut
qui vient des cendres qui vient d'angers
une petite partie de l'écran c'est un
peu moins discret et puis je dirais
qu'on a des bordures qui sont un poil
plus large sur le côté un poids là ça se
joue à pas grand chose et puis le menton
qui un peu plus proéminent donc on a un
design qui va être un petit peu moins
bien du côté de la face avant par contre
au niveau de la face arrière c'est
quasiment la même chose la seule
différence qu'on va venir retrouver ici
c'est que eh bien on va avoir un dos qui
va être mat au niveau du à 33,5 j'ai
toujours bien évidemment qui prend un
point les traces de doigts donc non ça
c'est un point de détail me direz-vous
tandis que sur le à 53 5 g on a un dos
qui est un peu plus brillant alors c'est
pas dingue quand on les met face à face
et qu'on regarde et qu'on compare on
voit pas une énorme différence comme ça
à l'oeil nu pose un peu loin mais je ne
vois pas trop faut vraiment les avoir
sous les yeux pour s'en rendre compte
mais il ya une petite différence côté
matt côté brillant même la voyez ce
n'est pas d'un bien c'est vraiment pas
bien alors c'est vrai que à 53 va être
un poil plus grand c'est quasiment la
même taille de châssis alors il ya un
truc qui est intéressant et qui a fait
samsung ici c'est que on a gagné en
épaisseur par rapport au modèle de
l'année d'avant autre truc qui est
intéressant que vous allez voir c'est
que sur la bordure qu'on a sur le à 53
de côté et bien on une bordure
légèrement coin légèrement incurvé
voiliers et brillant tandis que de
l'autre côté c'est là où on voit que
c'est effectivement maths alors mon chef
me direz-vous en terme de finition parce
que ça change vraiment grand chose pour
vous regardez cette vidéo pas
nécessairement mais si les petits points
de détails parce que quand on a deux
smartphones qui se ressemblent beaucoup
comme cela il faut réussir à les
différencier il faut qu'ils viennent
proposer quelque chose d'un peu
différent l'un et l'autre alors c'est
sûr que si vous les prenez sur la face
avant je crois que le côté différenciant
on peut pas se tromper on y est au
niveau de l'écran avec l'infiniti haut
et l'infiniti eu c'est clair mais sinon
au niveau de la r ça se ressemble
énormément donc voilà un peu pour le
côté design au niveau de ces deux
produits à noter qu'ici vous avez quatre
couleurs que ce soit pour l'un ou pour
l'autre vous avez une couleur bleue
alors ça c'est bleu j'aime bien sagement
que c'est la couleur que je préfère le
bleu est sympa alors si vous êtes plus
ce côté un peu fruitiers vous avez la
pêche un peu printanière plutôt sympa
également et puis vous avez les grands
standards lé grand classique vous avez
le blanc celui là et puis on retrouve le
noir le noir c'est vraiment le modèle
qui normalement se vend le plus parce
que plus standards plus classique tu dis
ce que je pense mais moi perso je pas ce
que vous en pensez d'ailleurs dit que la
main maintenant bas en commentaire le
modèle que je préfère c'est celui là
c'est le bleu que je trouve hyper canon
j'aime bien mais un côté frais léger
sympa ça sent la lavande simple et
voyager donc ça c'est plutôt cool et on
a ces quatre couleurs sur les deux
modèles le à 33 et le à 53 les deux
modèles ont également un capteur
d'empreintes digitales situé sous
l'écran pour venir déverrouiller
facilement donc c'est plutôt cool les
deux modèles ont des hauts parleurs
stéréo dolby atmos pour venir profiter
d'une expérience pour me regarder des
films des séries essayer ça et venir
s'amuser les deux modèles ont dû à 9 c
pour le paiement dématérialisé pour
samsung paye pour tout ce que vous
voulez et ils ont également tous les
deux du wifi 5 alors ici on se parle pas
de wifi si son garde le wifi 6 pour le
haut de gamme pour la gamme s pour la
gamme à on garde du wifi 5 et ils sont
tous les deux certifié ip67 c'est-à-dire
résistant à l'eau et à la poussière
alors on va un peu moins loin que
certification ip68 mais lorsque vous
allez vous balader qu'il pleut qu'il
tombe dans l'eau qu'on renverse envers
nos sans faire exprès dessus à deux
soucis tout ira bien donc ça c'est bien
ils ont tous les deux à l'avant un verre
corning gorilla glass 5 pour venir les
protéger contre les petites rayures donc
si vous y allez feront demi avec un
compas ça marchera pas ça m'a rayé mais
s'ils posaient des petites rayures du
quotidien ça conviendra et on garde bien
évidemment le corning gorilla glass
electus pour le haut de gamme on s'en
doutera et puisque c'est une donnée
importante lorsqu'on vient choisir un
smartphone ils ont tous les deux en un
10-2 réparabilité de 8,2 sur dix autres
qui est vachement intéressant et c'est
la première fois qu'on le voit arriver
c'est un nouveau processeur exynos qui
arrivent sur ces modèles là c'est le
1280 c'est un soft qui est gravée en 50
nanomètres c'est vrai qu'on avait
l'habitude faut que je regarde mais on
devait avoir je pense d snapdragon
l'année dernière faudrait vérifier de
qualcomm mais la c 1 1280 alors je le
connais pas celui là donc on va les
tester on fera les benchmarks lors du
test on vous dirai ce que j'en pense en
termes de performances pour du gaming
qu'est ce qu'on va pouvoir faire tourner
dessus qu'elles sont un peu les limites
mais cinq fois de plus on le verra
bientôt lors du test et on a une conflit
qu'on va retrouver sur les deux modèles
si giga de ram 128 go de stockage
extensible jusqu'à 1 tera et puis sur le
à 53 on a une différence vous pouvez
avoir une config un peu plus musclée
c'est à dire du 8 gigas de ram 512 giga
de stockage extensible également grâce à
une carte microsd sur les deux modèles
on va retrouver une grosse batterie de
5000 milliampères heures l'idée ici vous
savez c'est de pouvoir tenir deux jours
c'est la promesse qu'ils aient fait une
journée lui je pense qu'on va y arriver
au regard de rein pour les loas
puissante ou l'autre qui vachement
intéressante c'est pour la première fois
dans la gamme à et nous ont mis une
compatibilité avec un chargeur 25 watts
alors charger qui n'est pas inclus dans
votre boîte donc si vous voulez de la
recharge 25 watts il faut venir acheter
un chargeur 25 watts plus vous pouvez
trouver chez samsung d'ailleurs je vous
mets tous les liens en bas dans la
description vous permettra de le
recharger très rapidement à dire que
déjà vous l'avez mis la moitié de la
charge en peu moins de 30 minutes donc
ça c'est cool et c'est très rassurant
ici pas de charge sans fil et pas de
charge l'inversé non plus qu'on sent en
outre au niveau de l'écran qu'est ce qui
se passe ça nous intéresse ici sur le à
53 on a un grand écran de
6,5 pouces je voulais 10 un écran
infiniti haut avec le petit trou en eau
résolution full hd plus avec un taux de
rafraîchissement qui va à 120 hertz
alors ici on n'a pas d'adaptateur
attention à ça beau être une dalle super
amoled on n'a pas de techno ltp au donc
ici c'est soit du 120 hertz soit du 60
hertz c'est pas les deux il faut choisir
c'est soit l'un soit l'autre ça veut
dire que lorsque vous êtes en train de
regarder un film une série et compagnie
vous n'avez pas besoin d'avoir du 120
hertz vous mettez directement vous
souhaitiez vous le faites ou directement
ici dans vos paramètres vous passez en
60 hertz à venir consommer moins au
niveau de la batterie et lorsque vous
vous dites a laissé un peu vénère là je
veux mettre en jeu et je doute
d'ailleurs que ça des gones eh bien je
vais bien changé et je passe en 120
hertz et là je vais avoir le maximum de
fluidité attention par contre
l'autonomie derrière elle va baisser bon
voilà il faut faire des choix il faut
que vous vouliez faire les modifications
directement ici dans vos paramètres
tandis que sur celui là le à 33 on a une
dalle qui est un peu plus petit c'est du
site 24 pouces dont 6,4 pouces versus
6,5 poudrier ya pas non plus un écart de
dingue c'est vraiment génial ou ken
ishii avec l'écran infiniti ou infiniti
et puis le menton 6,4 pouces full hd +
super amoled également avec cette fois
ci un taux de rafraîchissement qui va
jusqu'à 90 ans on aura un peu moins de
fluidité mais je puis vous assurer 90
ans qu'on vient de jouer à des jeux ça
convient et y'a pas de souci là-dessus
alors ses smartphones on regarde des
séries on joue à des jeux on appelle ça
m'a mis on envoie des sms et on parle à
tous ses potes ça c'est bien mais qu'est
ce qu'on fait usage extrêmement
important c'est le fait de venir prendre
des photos des photos et des vidéos
c'est un usager nan parceque on a tous
besoin de souvenirs et puis il ya de
plus en plus de créateurs aujourd'hui on
vient partager nos contenus avec nos
amis on les met sur les réseaux ça c'est
chouette alors justement regarder on va
avoir 4 capte quatre capteurs d'un côté
et de l'autre alors je vous le dis sur
les 4 et 4 sont pas intéressants il y en
a un il y en a deux et éventuellement
qui vont être plutôt cool on regardera
ça une fois de plus lors du test faut
voir ça on a un grand-angle ici sur le
a50 364 mégapixels et ce 64 mégapixels
il est stabilisé stabilisation optique
et ça c'est très cool surtout pour moi
moi qui bouge des mains voyez comme ça
je mets ma petite up là je me mets comme
ça alors vous ne voyez pas parce que moi
je vois et c'est moi qui l'ait devant
moi mais s'est stabilisée et pour autant
mon smartphone il bouge ça s'est très
très bien qui nous les lycées sur le à
53 mais également sur l'a33 sur le
capteur grand-angle on a une
stabilisation optique et ça c'est une
vraie belle nouveauté qu'on retrouve ici
aujourd'hui dans cette gamme a et vous
avez un ultra grand temps pour venir
ouvrir lorsque vous êtes devant un
bâtiment voulu évoquer le grand temps
que ça suffit pas je peux pas reculer
nommément ultra-grand-angle là on est
sur un capteur de 12 mégapixels et puis
vous avez deux autres capteurs un
capteur macro et un capteur portrait
chacun de 5 mégapixels bon ça pour notre
portrait wide ça fonctionnera pour la
macro suis toujours un peu dubitatif
mais on va grâce à lors du test parce
que il faut pas être mauvaise langue et
puis vous avez à l'avant une caméra de
30 2 mégapixels pour me refaire des
selfs y est vous dire m'a regardé hop là
voilà ça c'est la classe fermée celle ci
alors il n'y a pas de stade 1 donc si
comme moi vous bouger c'est un peu le
bazar mais bon on peut pas tout avoir un
disque sur le à 33 vous avez également
quatre capteurs à l'arrière bah ouais
ils vont là dessus vous avez un
grand-angle de 48 mégapixels stabiliser
je voulais déstabiliser également un
ultra grand angle de 8 mégapixels un
capteur macro 2 5 mégapixels et un
capteur portrait de 2 mégapixels et à
l'avant on a une caméra tes filles de 13
mégapixels voilà comme ça vous savez
tout alors il ya plein d'autres modes
que samsung nous a mis en avant un mode
nuit qui va être beaucoup plus rapide
merci à l'exynos
1280 gravées en 50 nanomètres il permet
de gagner en performance et donc en
capacité de calcul pour les photos et
pour la vidéo on a un mode amusant alors
le mode amusant c'est quoi alors l'idée
du mot d'amour en fait c'est des films
qui sont développés en partenariat avec
nachat vous les avez directement ici
dans votre smartphone vous pouvez donc
faire des tronches qui vous feront
plaisir et les partager avec vos pâtes
et puis surtout les mettre sur n'importe
quel réseau s'est pas limité à ce match
est donc ça tout ça cool et vous les
avez sur votre capteur grand angle ultra
grand angle mais également la caméra de
celle ci et vous pouvez venir filmer ici
je tends 4k à 30 images par seconde
alors ses smartphones vous en douterez
ils sont pas gratos j'en aurais bien
mais non malheureusement il faut les
acheter alors le galaxy à 53 5 g qui je
pense est la star de la gamme a comme
les années précédentes cette smart
phones qui se vendent plus le tarif des
là alors vous avez sur la config 628
vous êtes à 459 euros et la version un
peu plus boosté pour aller un peu plus
loin en termes de stockage en termes de
performances et de fusils thé avec un
peu plus de ram 8 256 vous êtes à 519
euros tout en sachant que si vous voulez
l'acheter il est lancé officiellement le
1er avril c'est pas une blague vous avez
une préco ses marques et là je vous lis
en même temps c'est du 17 au 31 mars
vous avez des galaxies boys live qui
sont là qui sont offerts d'ailleurs j'ai
fait une vidéo pour vous parler des bugs
de samsung allez la voir si vous l'avez
pas vu comme ça vous saurez tout et vous
saurez tout sur ses galaxy 2 live il
vous avez en plus 50 euros offerts en
crédit sur google plaît donc ça ça vaut
le coup si vous voulez venir acheter des
choses acheter des jeux ou faire plaisir
vous avez un peu de crédit donc ça c'est
cool et le galaxy à 33 5 g lui il est à
379 euros et il n'y a pas de pré
commande pas d'offre 379 euros c'est le
prix pas plus pas moins et vous le
retrouvez bien évidemment sur le site de
samsung d'ailleurs je vous mets tous les
liens en bas dans la description pouvez
y aller vous cliquez vous regardez vous
pouvez faire votre choix et n'oubliez
pas que cible à 53 5 g vous fait de
l'oeil penser au preco parce qu'avoir
des petits bugs live offert avec et 50
euros de crédit sur google paye c'est
quand même plutôt pas mal voilà pour ces
deux smartphones alors on va y regarder
on va les tester sur tout le à 53,5 gec
est vraiment le smartphone qui
m'intéresse le plus parce que j'aime
coût s'est produit à 50 51 52 53 dans la
gamme de samsung dans la gamme galaxy ya
vraiment intéressant donc on va regarder
s'il tient ses promesses on va regarder
ce qu'il fait en termes de photos de
vidéos on va regarder c'est ce qui donne
en terme de performances notamment pour
venir jouer avec ces nouveaux
processeurs gravés en chacun domec
l'exynos 1295 va regarder s'il est
fluide s'il est intéressant et surtout
s'il est fait pour vous voilà donc ça on
en reparle très bientôt je vous invite à
faire quoi ben vous abonner une fois de
plus cliquez là ces petits boutons et
russel vous n'êtes pas volé puis surtout
et même si vous êtes abonné venez
actionner la cloche pour être notifié
dès qu une prochaine vidéo arrivera et
notamment le test du samsung galaxy à 53
ans la tromperie envers un peu plus tard
voilà vous embrasse pour les soins de
vous des bijoux et beaucoup d'amour
chaos
[Musique]